[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
conserving california applying whole
genome sequencing in the california
conservation genomics project
i am kaylee bach of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by sql
to learn more visit sequel.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
arielle hanik phd director of
applications and support at sql
courtney miller phd integrative biology
fund project manager for the california
conservation genomics project at the
university of california los angeles
and last but certainly not least
daniel oliveira
ms
california conservation genomics project
mini core technician at the university
of california los angeles
ariel
courtney and daniel you may now begin
your presentation
thank you for the introduction my name
is ariel hanik and i'm the director of
applications and support at sql
to tell you a little bit more about sql
we're a reagent company
that specializes in solving critical
bottlenecks and ngs workflows
specifically to enable high quality data
for more samples
over the past decade sequencing costs
have dropped due in large part to
increase sequencing capacity
this has made sequencing more accessible
for a wider range of applications but
also presents challenges on how to
effectively process and multiflex
hundreds or thousands of samples and
retain robust and high data quality
sql
flexwell library preparation kits were
designed specifically to meet this
challenge
the flexpod technology has three key
phases
sample barcoding pool barcoding and
library generation
during the sample barcoding phase
dna is tagged with an i7 barcoded
adapter by the sample barcoding or sd
reagent
samples with different i7 indices are
then pulled volumetrically into a single
tube before undergoing the second phase
pool barcoding
during the pool barcoding each sample in
the pool is tagged with an i5 barcoded
adapter
at this point each sample is dual
indexed with the i5 index tracing back
to the pool in the i7 index mapping back
to the sample
finally library fragments are amplified
using universal p7p5 primers
different pools use different i5 indices
enabling multiple pools to be sequenced
on the same flow cell
flexwell the plex method is a scalable
true multiplexing library prep
in a conventional workflow each sample
is qc'd undergoes library prep and then
a library qc
followed by individually normalizing
each library before before pulling it
for sequencing
with plexwell pooling is done after the
sample barcoding and the remainder of
the library prep is done in a
multiplexed fashion
a key point in the library prep is that
the iterative tagging steps
preserve sample recount within the pool
meaning that each sample has the same
coverage as is shown here in the blue
graph on the right
effectively plex file allows users to
pool early without sacrificing robust
performance
this in turn increases throughput during
library preparation reduces library qc
costs and alleviates normalization
burden prior to loading the sequencer
this approach makes flexwell suitable
for a wide range of applications
including single-cell rna-seq
high-throughput sequencing of synthetic
constructs whole microbial genome
sequencing metagenomics and microbe
sequencing screening
viral whole genome sequencing low-pass
whole genome sequencing and population
genomics
a specific interest here is conservation
genomics a subset of population genomics
in recent years it has growing interests
due in part to climate change
by utilizing ngs approaches researchers
are able to explore differences in
neutral and adaptive variation within in
between populations
to effectively make decisions on
conservation it's important to study the
breadth of variation within each species
this requires large scale sequencing
studies such as those conducted by the
california conservation genomics project
which aims to sequence 22 000 samples
across across a wide range of species
sql is excited to work with the ccgp to
develop a tailored flexwell protocol to
meet their project's needs
and with that i'd like to turn it over
to courtney miller
uh thanks arielle for the introduction
uh hello everyone my name is courtney
miller and i am the fund manager slash
project manager for the california
conservation genomics project
uh and i'm just going to take a brief
moment to give you some background on
the ccgp primarily i'll go over the
goals and scope of the project and then
i'll hand it over to dan olivera to get
into the technical part of this webinar
so the cctp's overall mission is to
provide california policy makers and
scientists with resources from genomic
data that will
inform conservation planning for the
state's species habitats and people in
the face of climate change and other
threats
now the cctp is a state-funded
initiative led by the university of
california los angeles la crete center
for california
conservation science but it involves a
consortium of conservation scientists
from across the whole state at the top
of this organization is
the scientific executive committee that
has representatives from five of the 10
uc campuses
also the california department of fish
and wildlife the u.s fish and wildlife
service and the governor's office
the whole team consists of about 70
principal investigators from across all
10 uc campuses and involves over
100 additional scientists such as grad
students and other collaborators
we also have a special collaboration
with the california department of fish
and of food and agriculture
to look at pest species across the state
and of course we work with a variety of
state federal and scientific partners
like sql
at various stages of the project
so
the overarching goal of the cctv is to
build the most comprehensive genomic
data set ever assembled for conservation
science
and it hopes to do this um first by
generating high quality reference
genomes for species across the state
and these will be publicly available on
the national database ncbi
also
generating whole genome sequencing data
for a geographically representative set
of samples um to map
map back to the reference genome to look
at things like genomic variation
and then
use the
best available
satellite imagery and geospatial mapping
to integrate the genomic data and
environmental data to make
meaningful statewide maps and tools to
show things like hot spots that are
climate resilient corridors to connect
those hot spots and identify critical
lands to
acquire and protect
finally the cctp will
communicate these results with important
environmental leaders and decision
makers to
maximize the impact of these efforts on
california conservation such as
determining what products and tools
would be the most useful for planning
but this whole genome sequencing
component is what we're really focusing
on today
so
just to dive a bit deeper into the scope
of the project the cctp involves roughly
230 species in every ecoregion across
the state of california
totaling over 20 000 individual samples
and these are all being collected by the
70 pis and their research teams
um here's a bit better look at the
taxonomic breadth of the project where a
dot on the map is an individual sample
locality so we have a bunch of plants
and green dots
in blue are all the marine species
marine plants vertebrates invertebrates
in purple we have insects and other
invertebrates
and in red we have all the terrestrial
vertebrates such as reptiles amphibians
mammals birds
the whole shebang
and here's where i turn it over to dan
to
actually talk about how he approaches
generating
whole genome sequencing data for such a
diverse group of texas
thank you for that introduction courtney
so as courtney mentioned my name is
daniel alvarez i am the lead tech for
the california conservation genomics
project specifically here at the mini
corps at the university of california
los angeles
so today i'm going to be talking about
our tissue sequence pipeline and
particularly how we're processing this
large
number
of non-model species
that courtney just talked about
so first to begin this i want to provide
some molecular historical background and
sort of why we're carrying out this
project
so the field of conservation genomics
has really evolved from the field of
conservation genetics
and conservation genetics really used a
reduced number of genomic markers or
loci for analysis typically relying on
microsatellites
more recent methods fall into several
categories including the first one you
can see here reduced representation
sequencing or genotyping by sequencing
the premise with this is that you're
targeting a small portion of the genome
rather than the entire thing we are
still able to get thousands of loci or
markers across the genome
there's pros and cons to each of these
methods so the pros are generally those
reduced costs per sample compared to
other methods you have the ability to
multiplex individuals into pools thereby
reducing costs again and for larger
genome species this is a good way to get
informative and representative data from
the entire genome
there's cons as well
mostly the fact that you are targeting a
reduced portion of the genome anywhere
from one to fifteen percent so it's
generally less informative
and also these regions are typically
neutral by default of the chemistry in
the protocol that you're carrying out
and these protocols themselves can also
be time intensive
another method that is recently emerging
and becoming more commonplace for
conservation genomics as more resources
are released
is whole genome sequencing or whole
genome resequencing so for this you're
targeting the entirety of the genome for
an individual
and the pros for this are that you're
targeting both neutral and genomic
regions so it is inherently more
informative
and you also generally get more uniform
sequence data from across the entire
genome and generally this method gives
more broad and informative data for
downstream analyses
the cons are generally that this it
requires a higher library and sequencing
cost compared to previous methods
and due to the fact that you're
targeting the entire genome um that
scales up pretty quickly in terms of
sequencing effort and costs so that
there could be less multiplexing
flexibility
depending on the input type and sample
needs
so this graphic here illustrates some of
this
and what you can see on the top is the
fraction of the genome that is being
sequenced
and in the middle you can see these
different methods i mentioned including
the reduced representation methods
and then on the far right you can see
the whole genome resequencing method
what's really important is the
implications that these particular data
types have on downstream analyses
on the bottom you can see different
types of population genomics analyses
and what we are really interested in as
courtney mentioned is
this association mapping and population
genomic scans
level of analyses so we really want to
get the most informative type of data we
can by capturing the majority of the
genomes of these individuals that we are
sequencing
so with this in mind
we chose to go the whole genome
sequencing approach for
sequencing all of our individuals for
this project and it really boils down to
the type of information we'd be getting
from this data and the information we
would need to really answer
questions regarding california
biodiversity
this leads us to an obvious next
question which really is
how we
how we can
leverage whole genome sequencing data to
utilize it in the most utmost
contemporary way to our advantage to
generate critical and informative
sequence data for the state of
california
so at one end this is a molecular
question of how we're going to
accomplish this
but it's also a pipeline development in
managerial questions since this is such
a large number of samples across a large
number of
projects and lab groups
and from this question three challenges
arise and stem from this the first one
is
how we're going to develop this pipeline
that can handle this large diversity of
sample types ranging from plant leaves
and whole insects to blood and muscle
bits
but also extracted dna that
individuals will be sending to us
and importantly these are a bunch of
non-model organisms as well
second is how we can use this above
pipeline to create and handle a
diversity of taxonomic groups
and like i just mentioned it's important
to remember many of these species have
either little or no molecular work done
on them
if they do the vast majority have only
been micro satellite work that is not
very informative for what we are trying
to accomplish
the third and last challenge is how we
can collect a whole genome sequencing
library prep method that ensures we are
not giving way on both financial and
handling time costs
for the sake of being able to process
different species and what i mean by
that is essentially how can we balance
our need to be efficient but also make
sure we're obtaining accurate and usable
data for the state of california across
all our species
in terms of what our organizational flow
chart looks like through this pipeline
this is sort of a very rough sketch of
what it looks like
and
uh i would just like to reiterate first
that moving forward uh courtney
mentioned we have 22 000 samples
expected only about half of these
samples are going to be processed
through the ccgp mini core that we are
running here at ucla
so that's sort of what i'm going to be
focusing on for the rest of this
discussion the pipeline for those
samples the rest of the samples are
going to be passing through
labs that have the molecular expertise
to sort of do the extractions and the
library of preps themselves and send
them off for sequencing
so the mini core was really founded in
order to emphasize
health for those labs that do not have
molecular expertise across the uc
campuses so we can really support them
to get
them this
type of sequence data
so as we focus on the organizational
chart here
samples enter through this pipeline on
the top left and they exit on the bottom
right when they're sent into sequencing
pools where we sequence them at the
university of california berkeley
on the novaseq s4
so the main takeaways from this
organizational chart are the different
stages or the different colors so the
blue represents stages for each sample
while the red represents the decision
steps
and then the yeah the orange represents
the different qc steps resulting from
the um
the stages and then the green represents
options of what we can do
so essentially this
this pipeline we've developed is pretty
structured for troubleshooting and
decision making in the sense that as
samples progress through the different
stages in blue we perform the different
qc steps and based upon the results from
those qc step we have decisions we need
to make and options we can go back to
such as asking pis for additional
samples doing re-extraction or
troubleshooting further so this allows
us to deal pretty efficiently with any
issues that can arise with any sort of
sample processes
so you might be wondering in practice
what does this pipeline look like for a
typical species project a species
project is a term that i'll use to
reference
about 120 to 150 samples per species
that we receive
so if we look at pipeline from start to
finish it generally takes about six to
seven days to go from tissue sample to a
sequence pool ready for sequencing
and the first step is through the
extraction and that takes about two days
to complete the extractions for all
those tissues for a species project
next it takes about one day to complete
the necessary quality checks to see
whether samples fail or pass that we can
relay that information back
to the lab that has submitted the
samples to us
it takes an additional day to complete
the normalization of samples and that's
extremely important just because we want
to get things in the right concentration
range for library press just because as
ariel mentioned things are going to be
full
so it's important everything is at an
equal concentration range going in
next it takes about two to three days to
complete the whole genome library prep
for all of individuals when it's in an
entire species project
and then carry out the necessary library
qc and cooling for sequencing
so now that we have a rough idea of
timeline it takes for samples to be
processed throughout our pipeline i'll
get into some more specifics of how we
address these challenges that i talked
about previously
our first two challenges are sort of
interlinked and we address them in
pretty similar ways and in particular
one major way
so that major way is following a batch
sample processing design so that we can
do this in increments of samples rather
than individual samples
or specific taxonomic groups at one time
additionally we made use of a liquid
handling robot that not only is capable
of doing dna isolations but also part of
the library prep method
up until pooling of individuals into
those libraries so using our ap motion
5075 liquid handling robot we can
accomplish a large portion of our
pipeline specifically with this dna
oscillations can be performed in batches
of 48 to 96 individuals
essentially as much as a default plate
will allow us to do
and to handle the diversity of sample
types as we mentioned we're handling
everything from plants to whole insects
to blood samples we use a variety of
specific reagents such as cdt and pvp
digest
and other methods such as seed
homogenization and overnight digestion
to maximize not only yields but also
increase the purity of our samples
and the majority of our dna
installations and protocols and scripts
provided for
our liquid handling robot are provided
by mockery nagel and a lot of these
extractions for the majority of these
extractions are bead-based which pair
pretty well with our little handling
robot
finally the last note i'll make is sql
squat technology allows us to make these
libraries in initial batches
of four totaling 96 multiplex
individuals and for us this is
incredibly useful because we do not have
to make individual libraries for each
sample throughout the whole library
process rather individual samples are
created in individual libraries through
the fragmentation process
and after that they are pooled which
allows us to make libraries in sets of
24 individuals which increases our
throughput
so
what exactly does this look like on the
day-to-day or a visual of what this
looks like on our robot you can see here
this is a picture i've snapped
a
mid extraction protocol you can see on
the robot you can lay out everything you
essentially need tips
wash buffers extraction plate the depot
plate
and in particular i'll focus on what's
circled here so this is the default
plate and it can hold upwards of 96
individuals
so we can really process a batch of
tissues pretty quickly in both an
automated and a hands-off manner
of course as many of you might know with
dna extractions there's always some fun
variations in how things turn out
so i included some of that here on the
left we have the digest material of
plant extractions so this is what i like
to call the extract
plant rainbow just because these are all
the same species but the digests range
in different shades from black to
different greens rounds even some goals
i would say
so it's just fun little things like that
that we get throughout the process
and on the right we also have some
issues that we need to troubleshoot as
well so if you can look really closely
in the middle you can see at the edge of
one of those tips there's sort of like a
brown glob
and this particular extraction was for
the california muscle and particularly
we're using tissue sample
a muscle tissue sample
and the polysaccharides and the mucus
for this particular species forms it
sort of finds
genetic extraction beads and the result
is when the
robot pulls up the washing floppers to
discard the washing buffer the mucous
filled beads and that have coagulated
sort of adhere to the tip and clog the
tip
so as you can see this doesn't come up
pretty frequently but it's through
things like this that we're able to
tweak our protocol in this case we
learned that next time we do an
extraction for the species
we need to use less input tissue and
that solves our issue
so through these little tweaks we're
able to standardize
are processed and create
text-to-specific protocols that are able
to handle the majority of
troubleshooting cases
in terms of library prep on the robot as
i mentioned previously the sql plexwell
library preparation kits
are partially automated up to that
everything up to the sb pooling set
which individuals are joined is the 24
sample library pools
so this is what it looks like on the
robot and just highlighting some key
points here
you can see then that the blue 96
well plate is where an individual sp
reaction occurs
so each individual is tag method with
the transpose enzyme so the dna is
essentially fragmented and then the i7
tagging reagents are added so with each
individual sparco disk and then on the
red circle on the right each three
columns are put into a single tube
creating a library containing 24
individual uniquely tagged individuals
another useful aspect of this kit and
how it has been prepared for us
is highlighted here on this white 96
well plate
and what these are these are the
pre-aliquoted i7 tagging reagents and
these contain
the fragmentation enzymes
that
that put right onto our liquid handling
robot so our robot can just very easily
move in
take aliquots from there and move them
into the blue sb reaction plate
and all we have to do is take the plate
out the robot take the play out of the
freezer saw it and place it on the
profile
so once off the robot the remainder of
the library prep process includes the pv
reaction step
which is the addition of a library
specific index and then we have the pcr
amplification step
and then a final size selection
resulting in dual index libraries
so a real limiting time factor here is
how many pooled libraries we can process
in our magnetic rack which in this case
is 12 libraries as you can see here
and that means if we accumulate
libraries from the automated process i
described previously
up to this point we can process 12
libraries for 288 individuals at once
which is well over an entire species
project and sometimes if a species
project is 130 individuals for example
we can process
two at the same time
now that i've outlined sort of what the
pipeline looks in action i want to talk
a little bit more about challenge number
three
so challenge three relates to how we can
balance our needs for an efficient
library prep method with processing with
a high processing throughput of
different sample types while also
limiting our financial and hands-on time
costs
so it
focuses on the blessing aspects but also
on how we can develop an efficient
pipeline
so i've addressed some of this already
particularly with the multiplex nature
of the flexwell kits that allows us to
pool and construct multiple libraries in
parallel
allowing us to scale up our throughput
across taxa across the entire project
but there's some other aspects that
make this kit really appealing and
useful for us
for example when we look at genome size
and taxonomic diversity we find that
within both libraries
for individuals
and sequencing pools that we send off
for sequencing with upwards of 96
individuals
we're able to tolerate variation in
genome size pretty well within the range
of 0.5 to 0.7 gb without any sort of
major impact on sequestering deaths or
other things
lastly
one major key advantage to the kit has
been our hands-on time is greatly
reduced due to the fact of the nature of
the kit itself due to the fact that it's
pooling
for almost half of the protocol
and the fact that the other half of the
protocol that is not pooled we're able
to automate that process
so that allows me to do other things on
the bench when the lust when the liquid
healing robot is pooling samples and
creating
initial libraries
so now that i've
sort of looked at the questions that and
challenges that we've had i wanted to
focus a little bit on
sort of the species we are working with
and species that we have completed
either pluxwell libraries for or that we
have recently received sequence data for
so i want to reiterate that although
we're still in this very much in this
data collection and data generation
phase of our project
we are excited for the next couple
months when we begin to complete all the
sequencing for various species projects
so
we have many different species within
this project but i wanted to highlight
some here
so on the left
this is the american ruby spot damn
supply this is one of our species our
insect species and for this particular
species we were given 137 tissue samples
to process for extraction and also to
complete library prep floor
in the middle we have an iconic species
most of you might know the species it's
the black bear so for this species we
were given 115 dna extractions that were
performed by someone else and we were
given the task of performing the library
prep method on those
next we have the sierra woodlowly fetal
and this is a very tiny insect species
and we were given 213 tissue samples
and to perform dna extractions on those
and get those ready for whole genome
library prep as well
so these are some three species we've
worked with and i'll highlight two more
on this slide
and as you can see on the left this
species it's the purple sea urchin so
for this one we have about 96
tissue samples that we were given
and we performed the dna extractions and
did the whole genome library prep for
these species
and finally on the right we have the
monkey face prickleback which is an
interesting name for a little marine
fish found off the coast of california
and for this we have 135 dna extractions
that were performed
and they were sent to us to do the whole
genome library prep
and one interesting takeaway from this
little showcase of species besides
showing a bunch of different taxonomic
groups in california
is to show that we have processed not
only a variety of sample inputs and what
i mean by that is that a lot of things
are for example the beetles are
processing whole insects we're also
processing blood samples or other things
such as the sea urchin which is
just little tiny spines that are given
to us so we're processing different
tissue types
but we're also handling dna extractions
as well
and the key is that we're able to handle
dna extractions that other people have
performed using various methods and
we're able to use all of those in a
common library prep method and show that
it's pretty robust
within our pipeline
that we have been able to
hold up to a variety of different taxa
and species demands and so the
difficulties that each one poses for
things like dna isolation or a during
library
process
now that i've showcased
some species we are working with and
then which we have data back for it's
also
useful to show
the track of the number of samples we've
received through the mini core thus far
so you can see here this is the
percentage breakdown of samples that we
have received at the mini core
and you can see a large portion of them
are in the yellow those are terrestrial
and vertebrates we've also received a
fair number of marine invertebrates in
the gray and also herbaceous plants in
the dark blue
and to see how this translates into the
number of samples we have sequenced so
far so for a lot of those those are
species you just previously saw
so for example sequenced by the mini
core you can see it reflects pretty well
the samples that have been submitted
a lot of the
terrestrial invertebrates have been
sequenced and a lot of the marine
invertebrates have been sequenced but
also a fair number of bird and mammal
species as well
you might notice that a lot of the
herbaceous plants have not been
sequenced yet and that is just due into
part that
plant extractions and preparation for
library prep require a little bit more
work so we have extracted many plant
species so we're excited to get them
into
libraries complete the library soon so
we can start developing a lot of this
novel sequence data for these plant
species in the coming months
if we look at all the ccgp species so
remember if we pan out some entirety of
this project only about half of the
samples are going through this dedicated
ccgp mini core down here at ucla
so if we look at samples that other labs
have been doing for their own molecular
work they're also required to submit
their sequence data to us so we can
perform these overarching bioinformatic
analyses on genetic diversity
so we see that overall for in all
samples in which we have sequence data
for for ccgp it aligns pretty well with
what i just showed you previously
we can see that the majority are marine
invertebrates once again but also a fair
number of terrestrial invertebrates and
a large number of birds that have been
sequenced as well
so this reflects the most accurate
numbers or percentages of a taxonomic
breakdown of sequence data that we have
for ccgp
now as i mentioned before we're still
generating a lot of the sequence data so
we do not have too much to report yet on
bioinformatics analyses or these goals
that we're trying to get that that
courtney mentioned but i did want to
highlight some data that we have
received
for some species so here this is just a
violent plot of two species
in which we're looking at the sequence
data yield that has come off right off
the sequencer
so on the right you can see
the sierra willow leaf lefetal or
crystal mella
and you can see that
a lot of the distribution of data that
we're getting back is around 11 to 5 or
6 gb
per individual
and on the left you can see the
aphylocoma which is the california scrub
jay this is another bird species that we
have in our project
and you can see this distribution is a
little less narrow but it still falls
within the range and thresholds of which
we need to meet our project
goals
and what we mean by that is for apple
coma we have an expected genome size
estimate of 1.21 gb
and
for the frequency that we have received
so far about 96 individuals that
we get an average of around 13
um gb per sample
and if we do some quick math that gives
us around 11x coverage per individual
and our aim here for coverage is really
to get at 10x
and to fall within a 6 to 12x range to
perform these subsequent analyses so
apocoma falls nicely within this range
and even for individuals that trail
they're trailing on a larger um coverage
range which is good for us
for chrysamela it actually looks a
little bit even better so
krishnamala has a smaller genome size
estimate around 0.6 gb
and per sample we get on average about
8.42 gb coming off the sequencer
and that translates to about 14x
coverage average per individual which is
well above the targets that we are going
for which is very nice so not only does
this show that we're hitting sort of
these metrics that we want to so far but
it's also important since this is a
pooled and multiflex approach it shows
that we're getting consistent sequence
yields for individuals within a library
pool now there's minimal concern that
individuals within a sequencing pool are
dropping out or failing once we receive
sequence data
so it makes us pretty confident that
we're getting um
useful and informative sequence data for
all individuals within a 24 sample pool
lastly if we're looking at absolute
numbers in terms of samples processed
we want to look at sort of where does
that leave us and currently the mini
core has
over 4 800 samples that we've received
for either
just whole genome library prep or for
either or for both dna isolation and
library prep we span a wide versus a
wide variety of taxonomic groups such as
blood and plant samples to whole insects
or muscle fragments
and a large portion of these 4 800
samples are tissues that we have already
extracted actually
in fact we have processed about 2 700
samples from tissue to extracted dna
using our automated extraction protocols
on our liquid handling rubra and this
includes plants vertebrate muscle whole
insects and blood samples
in terms of how many samples we have
sent out in preparative sequencing that
i mentioned earlier this is about 1300
samples
and you saw previously what that
taxonomic breakdown looked like
in terms of the entire ccgp project and
i showed you sort of earlier how that
taxonomic breakdown looks like as well
there's about
2300 samples that have been sequenced
and this includes the 1300 samples that
the main core has to offer sequencing as
well
so while we're still in this data
generation and collation phase we're
excited to keep pushing through the
taxonomically diverse sample types over
the next few months
and really get
through
the sequence data so we can perform
these informative analyses
just to wrap up i kind of want to bring
us back to our real main question of
interest that outlined um earlier in
this discussion
and really that's how we can go about
generating this vast amount of
informative sequence data for the state
of california on an effective scale
and while we have laid out how we have
gone about this on the molecular scale
but also on a pipeline generation
scale
and development phase
we have
also wanted to outline how we can
accomplish this for other projects that
are looking to develop similar
multi-species projects of their own
and i think there's a couple ways to go
about this first
the batched and automated processing
design is key since you're able with
this to develop an efficient protocol
that allows you to maximize sample
processing
across a variety of taxonomic groups and
sample types
next the flexible tips in particular are
useful since we can generate whole
genome sequencing data for non-model
species in a way that minimizes
financial and handling time costs
bringing up time and resources to focus
on other aspects of sample processing
such as dna isolation and those in
between qc steps
related to these kits that we're using
the multiplexing of samples across a
distribution of genome sizes on
different species really allows us to
capitalize and maximize on sequencing
efficiency on our sequencing platforms
that we're using essentially we can get
the most bang for our buck when sending
off samples for sequencing by including
the utmost number of individuals within
those pools
and finally our tissue the sequence
pipeline provides a degree of
normalization and standardization across
these different species and sample types
something that is really difficult to
achieve across multi-species projects
and includes things as far ranging as
plants to invertebrates and different
vertebrate species
so with all this in mind and sort of
keeping in the batch processing design
and sort of the pipeline you have
created to handle troubleshooting
species we think
the
tissue to sequence pipeline that we have
developed here is very informative for
other projects who are looking to
complete similar types of sequencing for
different taxonomic groups or just this
level of scale of sequencing and that
can be accomplished using our different
extraction protocols and scripts that
we've developed while also making use of
the whole genome sequencing library kit
such as the sql plex webkits
that is truly multiple multiplexing
samples across different genome sizes
and taxonomic diversity
and with that i just want to thank
everyone for coming to our webinar and
for all of our collaborators and
supporters throughout this project and
i'm happy to answer any questions that
anyone might have
that's just wanted to thank ariel
courtney and daniel again for their
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for
all right let's get started our first
question here asks you showed a nice map
of general types of samples
and where they were collected can you
expand on what specific types of plants
and animal species you have looked at
and how they were chosen
um yes i can help answer that question
i'm going to start with the last half of
it which is how they were chosen so the
ccgp focused kind of on three groups of
species um threatened and endangered of
course um commercially exploited and any
that are also looking at the kind of
opposite end of those which are
wide-ranging foundational species that
have um a lot of
ecological significance
so
when with cctp received all the funding
it sent out a call for proposals to help
meet the primary goals of the cctp so we
had
project investigators from all over the
uc system proposed target species of
sampling design research approach a
budget their team members and then those
awards were reviewed and by um
and then selected
for
participation in the ccgp and you know
we have
the specific species we have include um
you know grasses marine invertebrates
um
insects birds mammals
um the entire kind of tree of life
all right thank you courtney another
question here we have asks what did you
do before sequels tagmentation slash
transpose technology sounded like you
used a target amplicon
approach before and this allows for a
wider look can you provide more color on
what you move from and how it changed
your thinking
yeah so
essentially when we started with ccgp we
sort of went through that process of
deciding whether we're going to be using
a whole genome approach or the rad seek
approach and there are stick is pretty
similar to amplicon approach it's a
little different just because it's
random throughout the genome and i
believe with an
approach you're targeting specific
elements
um so we
we didn't within ccgp we didn't do any
sort of um
testing to look at
differences in data between this rad
seek approach or
whole genome sequencing we sort of just
decided to go with the whole genome
sequencing from the gecko
but there's sort of a long history of
labs that
have been in ccgp that have been using
rapid data so we did have a baseline
comparison
trying to look at what that data would
look like and trying to piece together
what would be most useful and
sort of at the end of the day we decided
to go with that whole genome approach
just because
um based upon previous research and
these labs it was more useful for whole
genome data
all right thank you daniel another
question we have here asks
where and how do you archive the samples
for later look or repeats
yeah i think i can also speak to that
question as well so
we do
for most samples for example tissue
samples that people send to us
for most of these we
don't use the entire sample
if they send us a bunch of lead samples
we're typically only using like a single
lease for extractions or things like
that so
we are keeping a lot of these samples as
well for
a limited amount of time just in case
we need to go back and do a
re-extraction or forget
um or complete the library and get
sequencing and things that go up here
sometimes you do need to go back into
those earlier steps
so we are keeping them sort of
throughout a short period of duration
while we're generating all this data and
in terms of where we're keeping them a
lot of these samples um
are able to just be kept in a minus 20
freezer or even at room temperature for
example for plant samples and they're on
dried bees and stuff like that so
we're keeping a lot of them just in case
you need to go back and look at things
again
thank you
next question here
what were the toughest specimens or
samples your team had to work with
yeah that's a good question
to pick out
my
artist samples and i think
to answer that question it sort of
depends on what aspect of the protocol
you're
working on so some some samples have
been sort of difficult at the extraction
step as i showed earlier
uh the muscle in particular was a
difficult species for the extraction
step just because
you can't put in too much tissue as you
would like because then you end up with
that weird globby
attraction to the magnetic beads and the
polysaccharides
so there's difficulties there
with the extraction set
and there's also some difficulties
post-extraction steps
in terms of gang samples pure enough
just so they're not interfering with any
like inhibition during
uh the tag mutation steps or the
um
the pcr steps as well
so some species for example like marine
plant species or other marine
invertebrate species or even
terrestrial herbaceous plant species as
well
can be difficult to work with as well
just because they have sort of
inhibiting compounds that can make
downstream steps difficult
all right thank you
all right next question are you working
with archival specimens from the museums
to look at species from the past and
what happened to them due to climate
change and compared to today's species
yeah all right
yeah i can talk maybe a little bit about
that um
so in terms of from a technical sort of
methodological standpoint um
we're not working
too much with sort of
deep archival or museum samples just
because
we want to get pretty good high quality
dna out from
these samples for the sort of library
prep steps
um so
the sort of a threshold where we can't
really work with uh samples that might
have served
of degradation or
dna degradation so there's sort of a
limit there from this technical step on
how far back we can pull samples
thank you
all right next question here how were
the specimens to be studied collected
that kind of follows up with what i was
saying earlier about these funded
projects that the cctp supports so it's
there's 70 different pis that have all
taken are have taken the responsibility
to collect the samples um with an
emphasis on geographic breath so it's
depending on if it's a plant or a marine
species they have managed their research
teams and their research labs to go out
into the field and collect those
specimens and then send them to us or
manage them in their own lab
great thank you
all right another question here it seems
that this project can also help other
international projects advance
will the tech specific dna extraction
protocols be made widely available
yeah i think that's a really good
question just because we're doing all
this work and it's really important to
let others know how we've done this work
so it can be sort of replicated in other
settings
um so a lot of these protocols like the
dna extraction protocols in particular
um
just sort of obtained from
the two particular companies we're using
macri nagel and then there's another
smaller company that we're using for the
marine inverts
so they're pretty easily attainable from
them but also on top of that once we
sort of get to this publication phase
and we're disseminating sort of our
results i think we're really interested
in sort of sharing
more specifics and details um on
this like tissue the sequence type one
as well so that can be replicated across
other projects so i think that's
something we're really interested in
doing in the future
all right thank you
this next question here is for courtney
how do you envision these sequences
being used to promote conservation
that's a great question
old goal of the project um so it's kind
of a two-part approach it's generating
um useful tools and data are useful data
and then tools and maps so it's taking
the whole genome sequencing data and
using it to
create these landscape-based analyses to
generate
state-wide maps and of such things like
i mentioned a bit in the intro but like
high and low vulnerability regions to
climate change corridors to connect
these regions just looking at sensitive
species um so taking these these
resources from the data and then also
communicating them to folks that make
the decisions in the state so working
with state policy makers and
stakeholders to to really work out what
the best strategy is to to use this data
and to apply it um with into management
practices
great we have so many great questions
coming in from our audience but it looks
like we have time for one more for the
session today and this last question
asks what pipelines are you using for
genome assembly it's our two part
question here the second part says are
you performing reference guided assembly
and are your reference genomes created
using long-range sequencing technologies
yes so the reference genomes are created
using its kind of two-pronged approach
with high fi bio hifi sequencing and
omni-c sequencing and then assembled um
and then kind of a little bit of
curation genome assembly curation and
then yes the whole genome resequencing
will be mapped to those to those rates
um using variant form a variant called
call format basically
well thank you again arielle courtney
and daniel for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor sequel
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye
you